Bonjour, bonjour et bienvenue sur ma chaîne YouTube
Elle est loin l'époque du "Yo tout le monde c'est Squeezie" hein ?
Aujourd'hui, on va se faire péter le cerveau
*Brah Brah*
Nous sommes sur ECHOLPEX. ECHOPLEX qu'est ce que c'est?
C'est un mot qui rime avec 'duplex', 'cornflakes'...
...
Voilà, plus de deux rimes c'était trop compliqué pour moi.
C'est un jeu dans lequel il va y avoir un écho de nous même
Qui va reproduire ce qu'on fait mais avec quelques secondes d'écart.
Vous suivez jusque là?
Si cet écho nous chope, nous mourrons...
...et nous perdons la partie!
Le but va donc être de passer les cinq niveaux de l'alpha...
...pour gagner!
Et pour se dire qu'on a été intelligent et se sentir bien.
Allez c'est parti, 'Play demo'
J'ai découvert ça avec vous et je sens qu'on va perdre dix mille fois
Donc ça je suppose c'est la porte d'où l'écho va sortir.
Attends je vais avoir peur quand je vais le voir cet écho de merde
Moi quand il y a de l'écho je vais sur 'Audacity' je met l'effet réduire l'écho...
... et il y a plus d'écho
Excellent!
Ah ! Mais enfait le level va être grand.
D'accord
Je sais pas à partir de quand
Heu...
L'écho va arriver
Mais je pense qu'il va arriver...
Ah ! Je peux aller dans cette pièce toute jaune.
D'accord
Ou la la...
Unlocked Hello Stranger
D'accord donc le premier level y'a pas de écho parfait !
ça aurai dû être finalement le premier niveau
D'UN AUTRE JEU
Qui s'appelle pas Echo-bidule
Ok c'est parti
On passe dans la porte
'Hello Stranger level 2'
OH !!!
Ok c'est bon il est là
Donc maintenant il répète ce qu'on fait
AH! Vous voyez la il reste à cet endroit là comme nous tout a l'heure
Le problème c'est qu'en passant cette porte ça a déverrouillé ça
Et que lui quand il va la passer il va le REDEVERROUILLEE
C'est bon on peut y aller
Ok est-ce que vous avez suivi ? C'est important
Explication en image
*J'ai attendu dans le coin pendant 8 secondes
Lorsque l’écho est arrivé j'ai traversé une sorte de portail
Qui a verrouillé la porte qui se situait derrière
Il fallait donc que j'attende que mon écho traverse ce portail à son tour
Pour ouvrir la porte que moi j'avais verrouillée moi même*
C'est compris?
18/20 Théo
Alice 2/20!
Alors..'TIGER TRAP level 3'
Ok donc là on passe là, ok l'écho vient d'arriver quand y'a ce p'tit truc, alors attend
Là, y'a une porte qui est verrouiller
J'pense qu'y faut..
...
...Passer la d'dans
Hop !
Ca déverrouille la porte qui est là
Attend j'sais pas c'que ça a fait
ça a dérouiller quelque ch... OH le batard !Ah nan c'est moi qui attendais t'haleur
Oh putain j'ai eu peur fils de chien
Mais j'peux passer du coup ?
Ouais c'est bon j'peux passer
Et là j'passe là
Hop, et ça verrouille la porte qui est là
Et donc faut que j'attende qu'il arrive
Pour pouvoir passer. C'est juste ça?!
Ah mais non!
Ouais c'est bon. haha J'ai eu un éclair de.. pas de génie... de bolosse !
Quand tu crois avoir un éclair de génie alors que pas du tout!
Putain il est long hein!
Allô!
Non c'est pas possible j'ai dû fermer une porte là, c'est pas possible!
Y'a un truc que j'ai dû verrouiller. Il devrait déjà être arriver!
Il est où? Qu'est ce qu'il fait ?!
Pourquoi il tourne en rond? AH! J'ai verrouiller la porte qui est là
MERDE! faut que je la déverrouille. C'est en passant là d'dans que je l'ai déverrouiller?
Ah c'est bon regardez j'lai réouverte.
Ok maintenant il peut v'nir! Faut tracer! Il m'a suivit ou pas?
Ou j'ai reverrouiller un truc? Mais non?
Mais non mais c'est un sketch!
*OUAAH*
*AAAH*
C'est bon, c'est bon, c'est bon, chui passer!
Chui passeeer!
Ok on est bon! *Woouh* Vous avez compris ou pas?
*Pffff* Explication en image.
Mon écho devait m'suivre je suis donc passer par une porte nommée la "PORTE A"
Derrière laquelle se situait le "PORTAIL A"
En passant à travers le "PORTAIL A" la "PORTE A" s'est fermée ce qui fait que mon écho n'a pas pu m'suivre
J'ai dû revenir en arrière pour que cette porte s'ouvre et que mon écho puisse me suivre
VOILA!
Je sais que ça vous plaît ces p'tites explications hein! Elles servent à rien parceque vous avez déjà tout compris mais elles vous plaisent!
Alors 'Lost Time'
Y'a d'jà deux portails d'entrée d'jeux. Attend mais...comment mon clone...
*WOW!*
Ah j'ai paniqué, j'ai paniqué
'Chui une grosse merde!
Quand j'passe là... Non Ok la porte n'est pas verrouiller c'est juste un truc abstrait Ok
J'vais passer
'Faut que j'attende que mon clone passe de l'autre côté de la pièce pour que ça ça s'ouvre
Ok ça s'est ouvert c'est qu'il est passer, je trace
What?
J'me suis enfermé?!
J'pense qu'il faut pas que je prenne trop d'avance en fait
C'est bon c'est bon
Ah merde j'me suis enfermé avec lui!
NOOOOOON!
J'ai pas compris là!... Qu'est ce qui ouvre quoi...attend...
Ok
AH MEEERDE! Ok j'ai compris
*I understood what...what iseuh* J'ai pas le temps de vous expliquer il reste 4 minutes 4, putain ça mets la pression.
En gros quand il passe ici, ça ouvre la porte qui est de l'autre côté, mais quand il passe ici, ça la ferme.
Donc le mieux c'est que je temporise entre les deux, que j'ai l'temps de passer, voilà c'est bon
Et là normalement j'lai ken
Z'avez compris où pas?
Les explication en direct live, là normalement l'éducation nationale me donne mon diplôme de professeur quoi chui désolé mais là...
Alors ici qu'est ce qui se passe? On as un portail d'entrée d'jeu
Oh putain y'a deux portail, à quoi ça peut servir?
Ah j'pense qu'il faut qu'il vienne...
...Ok
Faut qu'il passe à travers comme ça ça la ré-ouvre non?
Ok ça l'a ouvert
Et comment j'ouvre ça?
Chui baiser là, merde!
Alors attendez ce level s'était un...*hmpf*... c'était un calvaire
En gros là on a un premier portail, Je ne sais pas à quoi il sert mais je pense qu'il doit ouvrir une porte bleu
OK
La porte bleu qui es là-bas!
Voilà, vu qu'il vient de passer à travers ce gros FDP ça l'a fermée
Donc c'qu'on vas faire c'est très simple c'est qu'on va temporisé ici
On vas attendre le plus qu'on peut
Puis on vas temporisé ici, on vas attendre le plus qu'on peut
Puis on vas y aller
C'est d'la merde...
*PHAHA*
Non j'pense juste qu'il faut temporisé ici et MAINTENANT y aller!
Voilà, comme ça il passera pas à travers et moi j'aurais le temps de passer
*AAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAH*
NOOON!
*AAH* Fils de pute!
*haha*
J'ai une théorie, vas-y passe
Si j'vais là...
AAAAH Ok c'est bon, j'trouver, j'trouver, j'trouver!
Enfaite faut l'faire courir, là j'vais attendre ici et normalement j'devrais peut-être avoir le temps de...
...passer...
...
*AAAAAAAAAAAAAH*
Comment ça m'fous les boules mec
OK, si on récapitule: le portail bleu ici présent que je viens de passer permet d'ouvrir la porte qu'il y as juste là à droite, la porte bleu.
Le problème c'est que j'ai pas le temps de l'atteindre parce qu'elle se ferme avant
Le portail jaune ici permet de bloquer mon double.
Et quand j'le bloque qu'est ce qu'il fait?
Il repasse là-bas...
'Tain mais c'est juste ça attend ça s'trouve, fallait que je le bloque comme ça il fait demi-tour et j'ai le temps d'y aller
*OOOOOOOOH*
*OOOOOHAHA*
AH C'EST FRUSTRANT!
Logiquement il va retourner derrière le bleu là, j'ai pas tout compris à c'que j'ai fait mais j'crois qu'il va retourner derrière le bleu et qu'on vas pouvoir passer
Normalement là ça va s'ouvrir
'Time's up'...
OH NON...NON
J'vous jure que ça allait s'ouvrire, m'en bats les couilles j'vous refaits tout en 2-2, aller c'est parti
*musique*
Ok nous y revoilà, cette fois on a huit minutes onze pour y arriver, autant vous dire que ça va le faire
Donc à mon avis, là je viens d'ouvrir la porte qu'il y avait là-bas, Ok, quand je vais là, hop, ça verrouille cette porte là
Et je suis persuadé qui a un truc à faire, pour que ce con...soit bloqué
Et que je gagne du temps sur la 'loop', à mon avis c'est ça
Attend comment on peut faire c'est compliqué, putain c'lui là il est en train de me CASSER L'CERVEAU mec
En gros là chui en train de le faire beuger, c'est à dire qu'il veut faire le mouvement que j'ai fait mais il beu... MERDE!
Oh non jm'attendais à expliquer un truc ça a foiré
ça y est il a beugé
ça y est il a beugé, j'crois qu'il est entrain de faire une loupe infinie parce que... YES
YES!
C'est ça!
Vous vous êtes échapper de l 'ECHOPLEX'
*WOUW*
*musique*
C'est malin  avoir compris, enfaite, donc, l' Echo de toi-même reproduit les mouvements que tu fais avec 4 secondes de décalage
Sauf que des fois il veut reproduire ce que tu fait mais y'a une porte qui vas le bloquer
Et quand il y a une porte qui le bloque il reprends la 'loop' à partire de 5 seconde avant
Et c'est ce qui s'est passer dans ce dernier niveau
Quand je suis parti dans la salle où il y as la porte pour s'échapper du niveau il as voulu me suivre mais la porte jaune s'est fermée devant lui,
Il as donc repris la 'loop' à partir de 5 seconde avant, et 5 seconde avant il était de l'autre côté du portail bleu, ce qui fait qui ma ouvert la porte de la sortie et que j'ai pu m'en aller
Le fait est que j'ai pas trop compris comment la porte jaune à pu se fermée...
...
...merde, aaaaah ça m'a péter l'cerveau, j'arrive pas à comprendre
Bon en tout cas c'est un putain jeu! J'espère que ça vous as plus n'hésitez pas à aimer la video si c'est l'cas
N'hésitez pas aussi à soutenir ce jeu sur 'Steam Greenlight'
Parcequ'il faut absolument que ça sorte sur Steam c'est trop ouf
La moitié des trucs comme ça que j'arrive à résoudre, j'y arrive et je sais pas comment j'ai fais, c'est horrible
Finalement c'est ce qu'on appelle "la chance et l’incompétence"!
Aller à tout de suite pour une prochaine vidéo, merci d'avoir regarder j’espère que ce petit jeu 'mindfuck' vous aura plu
Ciao tout le monde
PEACE!
*musique*